85% des français ont déjà acheté en
ligne
une pratique courante aujourd'hui mais
saviez-vous que tout a commencé dans les
années 60
à cette époque pas d'internet mais des
catalogues papier des courriers et des
commandes par téléphone
mais la vente par correspondance n'était
pas aussi prisé qu'aujourd'hui par
rapport au système de vente
traditionnels la vente par
correspondance ne représente en france
que 1 % en 1967 ces sociétés de vente
par correspondance avait exactement les
mêmes arguments commerciaux
qu'aujourd'hui l'intérêt de cette forme
de distribution par rapport à la
distribution traditionnelle
c'est de permettre aux clients éventuels
de pouvoir effectuer son choix
chez lui en famille assis dans son
fauteuil
les commandes se faisait sur la table du
salon avec un stylo en main pour remplir
le bon sens prend que touche vers une
fois le shopping sur papier glacé
terminé il fallait envoyer la commande
par lettre hélas pour les vendeurs
s'étaient tout comme aujourd'hui une
course contre la montre
à partir de la réception de lettres 120
kg reçus chaque jour la rapidité de
livraison constitue l'impératif numéro
un et après 15 jours à trois semaines
c'était l'heure de déballer le coni que
ça représente pour vous la
correspondance sa présence beaucoup de
choix au moment les balles un colis on
sait ce qu'on a acheté quatre jours la
surprise la préoccupe eu la satisfaction
des enfants dans les années soixante dix
la vente par correspondance explose les
entreprises s'industrialise et pour
aller toujours plus vite
elle propose de passer commande par
téléphone
en 1975 la vente par correspondance
avait progressé de 19% en un an
seulement
il y est tu n'es pas que la vente par
correspondance adressée surtout aux
habitants des campagnes parce que ceux
ci n'avaient pas dans leur village la
liberté de choix que fournit la
multiplicité des magasins en ville
aujourd'hui la tendance s'est renversée
et ce sont 55 % de citadins pour 45% de
ruraux qui achètent par correspondance
mais malgré ce boom certains restés
sceptiques quant à cette nouvelle
pratique de consommation pourquoi les
images malgré cette défiance la vente à
distance a continué de progresser et les
entreprises de vente par correspondance
ont réussi le virage internet les 3
suisses par exemple ont lancé en 1995
leur premier site de vente en ligne
faisant figure de pionnier français du
commerce sur le net
[Musique]